The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Just to review where we are,
we've been talking about
source coding as one of the
two major parts of digital
communication.
Remember, you take sources,
you turn them into bits.
Then you take bits and you
transmit them over channels.
And that sums up the
whole course.
This is the part where you
transmit over channels.
process the sources.
We're concentrating now on the
source side of things.
Partly because by concentrating
on the source
side of things, we will build
up the machinery we need to
look at the channel
side of things.
The channel side is really more
interesting, I think.
Although there's been a great
deal of work on both of them.
They're both important.
And we said that we could
separate source coding into
three pieces.
If you start out with a waveform
source, the typical
thing to do, and almost the only
thing to do, is to turn
those waveforms into sequences
of numbers.
Those sequences might
be samples.
They might be numbers
in an expansion.
They might be whatever.
But the first thing you almost
always do is turn waveforms
into a sequence of numbers.
Because waveforms are just too
complicated to deal with.
The next thing we do with
a sequence of numbers is
quantize them.
After we quantize them
we wind up with a
finite set of symbols.
And the next thing
we do is, we take
that sequence of symbols.
And --
and what we do at that point
is to do data compression.
So that we try to represent
those symbols with as small as
possible a number of binary
digits per source symbol.
We want to do that in such
a way that we can receive
it the other end.
So let's review a little bit
about what we've done in the
last couple of lectures.
We talked about the
Kraft inequality.
And the Kraft inequality, you
remember, says that the
lengths of the codewords in any
prefix-free code have to
satisfy this funny
inequality here.
And this funny inequality, in
some sense, says if you want
to make one codeword short, by
making that one codeword
short, it eats up a large
part of this fraction.
Since this sum has to be less
than or equal to 1.
If, for example, you make l sub
1 equal to 1, then that
uses up a half of this
sum right there.
And all the other codewords
have to be much longer.
So what this is saying,
essentially, and we proved it,
and we did a bunch of things
with it, and your homework you
worked with it, we have
shown that that
inequality has to hold.
The next thing we did is, given
a set of probabilities
on a source, for example, p1
up to p sub m, by this time
you should feel very comfortable
in realizing that
what you call these symbols
doesn't make any difference
whatsoever as far
as any matter of
encoding sources is concerned.
The first thing you can do, if
you like to, is take whatever
name somebody has given to a set
of symbols, replace them
with your own symbols, and the
easiest set of symbols to use
is the integers 1 to m.
And that's what we
will usually do.
So, given this set of
probabilities, and they have
to add up to 1, the Huffman
algorithm is this ingenious
algorithm, very, very, clever,
which constructs a prefix-free
code of minimum expected
length.
And that minimum expected length
is just defined as the
sum over i, of p sub
i times l sub i.
And the trick in the algorithm
is to find that set of l sub
i's that satisfy this inequality
but minimize this
expected value.
Next thing we started to talk
about was a discrete
memoryless source.
A discrete memoryless source
is really a toy source.
It's a toy source where you
assume that each letter in the
sequence is independent, and
equally independent, and
identically distributed.
In other words, every
letter is the same.
Every letter is independent
of every other letter.
That's more appropriate for a
gambling game than it is for
real sources.
But, on the other hand, by
understanding this problem,
we're starting to see that we
understand the whole problem
of source coding.
So we'll get on with
that as we go.
But, anyway, when we have a
discrete memoryless source,
what we found -- first we
defined the entropy of such a
source as h of x, which is the
sum over i of minus p sub i,
of logarithm of p sub i.
And that was just something that
came out of trying to do
this optimization not the way
that Huffman did it but the
way that Shannon did it.
Namely, Shannon looked at this
optimization in terms of
dealing with entropy and
things like that.
Huffman dealt with it in terms
of finding the optimal code.
One of the very surprising
things is that the way Huffman
looked at it, in terms of
entropy, is the way this
really valuable, even though
it doesn't come up with an
optimal code.
I mean, here was poor Huffman,
who generated this beautiful
algorithm, which is
extraordinarily simple, which
solved what looked like
a hard problem.
But yet, as far as information
theory is concerned, he used
that algorithm, sure.
But as far as all the
generalizations are concerned,
it has almost nothing
to do with anything.
But, anyway, when you look at
this entropy, what comes out
of it is the fact that the
entropy of the source is less
than or equal to the minimum
number of bits per source
symbol that you can come up with
in a prefix-free code,
which is less than
h of x plus 1.
And the way we did that was just
to try to look at this
minimization.
And by looking at the
minimization, we usually
showed it had to be greater
than or equal to H of x.
And by looking at any code
which satisfied this
inequality with any
set of length --
well, after we looked at this,
this said that what we really
wanted to do was to make the
length of each codeword minus
log of p sub i.
That's not an integer.
So the thing we did to get this
inequality is said, OK,
if it's not an integer, we'll
raise it up the next value.
Make it an integer.
And as soon as we do that, the
Kraft inequality is satisfied.
And you can generate a code
with that set of lengths.
So that's where you get
these two bounds.
This bound here is usually
very, very weak.
Can anybody suggest the almost
unique example where this is
almost tight?
It's a simplistic sample
you can think of.
It's a binary source.
And what binary source has the
property that this is almost
equal to this?
Anybody out there?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Make it almost
probability 0
and probability 1.
You can't quite do that because
as soon as you make
the probability of the 0, 0,
then you don't have to
represent it.
And you just know that it's
a sequence of all 1's.
So you're all done.
And you don't need any
bits to represent it.
But if there's just some very
tiny epsilon probability of a
0 and a big probability of a 1,
then the entropy is almost
equal to 0.
And this 1 here is needed
because l bar min is 1.
You can't make it any
smaller than that.
So, that's where that
comes from.
Let's talk about entropy
just a little bit.
If we have an alphabet which
has size m, which is the
symbol we'll usually use
for the alphabet, x.
And the probability that
x equals i, is p sub i.
In other words, again, we're
using this convention so we're
going to call the symbols the
integers 1 to capital M. Then
the entropy is equal to this.
And a nice way of representing
this is that the entropy is
equal to the expected value
of minus the logarithm.
Logarithms are always to the
base 2, in this course.
When we want natural logarithms
we'll write ln, in
other words it's log
to the base 2.
So it's log to the base
2 of the probability
of the symbol x.
We call this the log pmf
random variable.
We started out with x being
a chance variable.
I mean, we happen to have
turned it into a random
variable because we've
given it numbers.
But that's irrelevant.
We really want to think of
it as a chance variable.
But now this quantity is a
numerical function of the
symbol which comes out
of the source.
And, therefore, this
quantity is a
well-defined random variable.
And we call it the log
pmf random variable.
Some people call it
self-information.
We'll find out why later.
I don't particularly
like that word.
One, because what we're dealing
with here has nothing
to do with information.
Probably the thought that this
all has something to do with
information, namely, that
information theory has
something to do with
information, probably held up
the field for about
five years.
Because everyone tried to figure
out, what does this
have to do with information.
And, of course, it had nothing
to do with information.
It really only had
to do with data.
And with probabilities of
various things in the data.
So, anyway.
Some people call it
self-information and
we'll see why later.
But this is the quantity
we're interested in.
And we call it log pmf,
we sort of forget
about the minus sign.
It's not good to forget
about the minus sign,
but I always do it.
So I sort of expect other
people to do it, too.
One of the properties of entropy
is, it has to be
greater than or equal to 0.
Why is it greater than
or equal to 0?
Well, because these
probabilities here have to be
less than or equal to 1.
And the logarithm of something
less than or
equal to 1 is negative.
And therefore minus the
logarithm has to be greater
than or equal to 0.
This entropy is also less than
or equal to log M, log capital
M. I'm not going to
prove that here.
It's proven in the notes, it's
a trivial thing to do.
Or maybe it's proven in one
of the problems, I forget.
But, anyway, you can do it using
the inequality log of x
is less than or equal
to x minus 1.
Just like all inequalities
can be proven with that
inequality.
So there's a quality here
if x is equiprobable.
Which is pretty clear, because
if all of these probabilities
are equal to 1 over M, and you
take the expected value of
logarithm of M, you get
logarithm of M. So there's
nothing very surprising here.
Now, the next thing -- and
here's where what we're going
to do is, on one hand very
simple, and on the other hand
very confusing.
After you get the picture of
it, it becomes very simple.
Before that, it all looks
rather strange.
If you have two independent
chance variables, say x and y,
then the choice where the sample
value of the chance
variable x, and the choice of
the sample value y, together
that's a pair of sample values
which we can view as one
sample value.
In other words, we can view xy
as a chance variable all in
its own right.
This isn't the sequence x,
followed by y, where you can
think of it that way.
But we want to think
of this here as a
chance variable itself.
Which takes on different
values.
And the values it takes on are
pairs of sample values, 1 from
x, 1 from ensemble y, and xy
takes on the sample value of
little xy with the probability
p of x times p of y.
As we move one with this course,
we'll become much less
careful about putting these
subscripts down, which talk
about random variables.
And the arguments which talk
about sample values of those
random variables.
I want to keep doing it for a
while because most courses in
probability, even 6.041, which
is the first course in
probability, almost deliberately
fudges the
difference between sample values
and random variables.
And most people who work
with probability do
this all the time.
And you never know when you're
talking about a random
variable and when you're talking
about a sample value
of a random variable.
And that's convenient for
getting insight about thing.
And you do it for a while and
then pretty soon you wonder,
what the heck is going on.
Because you have no idea what's
a random variable any
more, and what's a sample
value of it.
So, this entropy, H, of the
chance variable, xy, is then
expected value of minus the
logarithm of the probability
of the chance variable, xy.
Mainly, when you take the
expected value, you're taking
the expected value of
a random variable.
And for the random variable
here, in the chance variables,
xy and here.
This is the expected value of
minus the logarithm of p of x
times the probability p of x.
Which is the expected value.
Since they're independent of
each other it's the sum.
And that gives you H of x y is
equal to H of x plus H of y.
This is really the reason why
you're interested in these
chance variables which are
logarithms of probabilities.
Because when you have
independent chance variables
then you have the situation that
probabilities multiply
and therefore log probabilities
add.
All of the major theorems in
probability theory, in
particular the law of large
numbers, which is the most
important result in probability,
simple though it
might be, that's the key to
everything in probability.
That particular result talks
about sums of random variables
and not about products
of random variables.
So that's why Shannon did
everything in terms
of these log PMF.
And we will soon be doing
everything in
terms of log PMF also.
So now let's get back to
discrete memoryless sources.
If you now have a block of n
chance variables, x1 to xn,
and they're all IID, again we
can do this whole block as one
big monster chance variable.
If each one of these takes on
m possible values, then this
monster chance variable
can take on m to
the n possible values.
Namely, each possible string
of symbols, each possible
string of n symbols where each
one is a choice from the
integers 1 to capital M. So
we're talking about tuples of
numbers now.
And those are the values that
this particular chance
variable, x sub n, takes on.
So it takes on these
probabilities, takes on these
values with the probability p
of x n is the product from i
equals 1 to n, of the individual
probabilities.
In other words, again, when you
have independent chance
variables, the probabilities
multiply.
Which is all I'm saying here.
So the chance variable x sub
n has the entropy H of x n,
which is the expected value of
minus the logarithm of that
probability.
Which is the expected value of
minus the logarithm of the
product of probabilities, which
is the expected value of
the sum of minus the log of the
probabilities, which is n
times H of x.
If you compare this with the
previous slide, you'll see I
haven't said anything new.
This argument and this
argument are
really exactly the same.
All I did was do it for two
chance variables first.
And then observe.
But it generalizes,
to an arbitrary
number of chance variables.
You can say that it generalizes
to an infinite
number of chance
variables also.
And in some sense it does.
And I would advise you
not to go there.
Because you just get tangled up
with a lot of mathematics
that you don't need.
So the next thing is, how
do we fix the variable
prefix-free codes and what
do we gain by it?
So the thing we're going to do
now, instead of trying to
compress one symbol at a time
from the source, we're going
to segment the source into
blocks of n symbols each.
And after we segment it into
blocks of n symbols each,
we're going to encode the
block of n symbols.
Now, what's new there?
Nothing whatsoever is new.
A block of n symbols is just
a chance variable.
We know how to do optimal
encoding of chance variables.
Namely, we use the Huffman
algorithm.
You can do that here
on these n blocks.
We also have this nice theorem,
which says that the
entropy -- well, first the
entropy of x n as n times the
entropy of x.
So, in other words, when you
have independent identically
distributed chance variables,
this entropy is just n times
this entropy.
But the important thing
is this result
of doing the encoding.
Which is the same result
we had before.
Namely, this is the result of
what happens when you take a
set -- when you take an
alphabet, and the alphabet can
be anything whatsoever.
And you encode that alphabet in
an optimal way, according
to the probabilities of each
symbol within the alphabet.
And the result that you get is
the entropy of this big chance
variable x sub n is less than
or equal to the minimum --
well, it's less than or equal
to the expected value of the
length of a code, whatever
code you have.
But when you put the minimum on
here, this is less than the
entropy of the chance variable
x super n plus 1.
That's the same theorem
that we proved before.
There's nothing new here.
Now, if you divide this by n,
this by n, and this by n, you
still have a valid inequality.
When you divide this by
n, what do you get?
You get H of x.
When you divide this by n,
by definition L bar --
what we mean is the number of
bits per source symbol.
We have n source symbols here.
So when we divide by n, we get
the number of bits per source
symbol in this monster symbol.
So l min is equal to this.
When we divide this
by n, we get this.
When we divide this by
n, we get H of x.
And now the whole reason for
doing this is, this silly
little 1 here, which we're
trying very hard to think of
as being negligible or
unimportant, has suddenly
become 1 over n.
And by making n big enough,
this truly is unimportant.
If you're thinking in terms of
encoding a binary source, this
1 here is very important.
In other words, when you're
trying to encode a binary
source, if you're encoding one
letter at a time, there's
nothing you can do.
You're absolutely stuck.
Because if both of those
letters have non-zero
probabilities, and you want a
uniquely decodable code, and
you want to find codewords for
each of those two symbols, the
best you can do is to have
an expected length of 1.
Namely, you need 1 to encode 1,
and you need 0 to encode 0.
And there's nothing else,
there's no freedom at
all that you have.
So you say, OK, in that
situation, I really have to go
to longer blocks.
And when I go to longer
blocks, I
can get this resolved.
And I know how to do it.
I use Huffman's algorithm
or whatever.
So, suddenly, I can start to
get the expected number of
bits per source symbol.
Down as close to h of x
as I want to make it.
And I can't make
it any smaller.
Which says that H of x now has
a very clear interpretation,
at least for prefix-free codes,
of being the number of
bits you need for encoding
prefix-free codes when you
allow the possibility
of encoding them
a block at a time.
We're going to find later today
that the significance of
this is far greater
than that, even.
Because why use prefix-free
codes, we could use any old
kind of code.
When we study the Lempel-Ziv
codes tomorrow, we'll find out
they aren't prefix-free
codes at all.
They're really variable length
of variable length codes.
So they aren't fixed
to variable length.
And they do some pretty fancy
and tricky things.
But they're still limited
to this same inequality.
You can never beat the
entropy bound.
If you want something to be
uniquely decodable, you're
stuck with this bound.
And we'll see why in a very
straightforward way, later.
It's a very straightforward way
which I can guarantee all
of you are going to look at it
and say, yes, that's obvious.
And tomorrow you will look at it
and say, I don't understand
that at all.
And the next day you'll
look at it again and
say, well, of course.
And the day after that you'll
say, I don't understand that.
And you'll go back and forth
like that for about two weeks.
Don't be frustrated, because
it is simple.
But at the same time it's
very sophisticated.
So, let's now review the weak
law of large numbers.
I usually just call it the
I bridle a little bit when
people call it weak because,
in fact it's the centerpiece
of probability theory.
But there is this other thing
called the strong law of large
numbers, which mathematicians
love because it lets them look
at all kinds of mathematical
minutiae.
It's also important,
I shouldn't
play it down too much.
And there are places where
you truly need it.
For what we'll be doing, we
don't need it at all.
And the weak law of large
numbers does in fact hold in
many places where the strong
law doesn't hold.
So if you know what the strong
law, is temporarily forget it
for the for the rest
of the term.
And just focus on
the weak law.
And the weak law is not
terribly complicated.
We have a sequence of
random variables.
And each of them has
a mean y bar.
And each of them has a variance
sigma sub y squared.
And let's assume that they're
independent and identically
distributed for the
time being.
Just to avoid worrying
about anything.
If we look at the sum of those
random variables, namely a is
equal to y1 up to y sub n.
Then the expected value of a is
the expected value of this
plus the expected valuable
of y2, and so forth.
So the expected value of
a is n times y bar.
And I think in one of the
homework problems, you found
the variance of a.
And the variance of a, well, the
easiest thing to do is to
reduce this to its
fluctuation.
Reduce all of these to
their fluctuation.
Then look at the variance of the
fluctuation, which is just
the expected value
of this squared.
Which is the expected value of
this squared plus the expected
value of this squared,
and so forth.
So the variance of a is n times
sigma sub y squared.
I want all of you know that.
That's sort of day two of
a probability course.
As soon as you start talking
about random variables, that's
one of the key things
that you do.
One of the most important
things you do.
The thing that we're interested
in here is more the
sample average of y1
up to y sub n.
And the sample average,
by definition, is the
sum divided by n.
So in other words, the thing
that you're interested in here
is to add all of these
random variables up.
Take one over n times it.
Which is a thing we
do all the time.
I mean, we sum up a lot of
events, we divide by n, and we
hope by doing that to get some
sort of typical value.
And, usually there is some sort
of typical value that
arises from that.
What the law of large numbers
says is that there in fact is
a typical value that arises.
So this sample value is
a over n, which is the
sum divided by n.
And we call that the
sample average.
The mean of the sample average
is just the mean of a, which
is n times y bar,
divided by n.
So the mean of the sample
average is y bar itself.
The variance of the sample
variance, --
the variance of the sample
average, OK, that's, --
I'm talking too fast.
The sample average here, you
would like to think of it as
something which is known
and specific, like
the expected value.
It, in fact, is a
random variable.
It changes with different
sample values.
It can change from almost
nothing to very large
quantities.
And what we're interested in
saying is that most of the
time, it's close to the
expected value.
And that's what we're
aiming at here.
And that's what the law
of large numbers says.
The sample average here, the
variance of this, is now equal
to the variance of a divided
by n squared.
In other words, we're trying to
take the expected value of
this quantity squared.
So there's a 1 over n squared
that comes in here.
When you take the 1 over n
squared here, this variance
then becomes sigma --
I don't know why I
have the n there.
Just take that n out,
if you will.
I don't have my red
pen with me.
And so it's the variance
of the random variable
y, divided by n.
In other words, the limit as n
goes to infinity of the of the
variance of the sum is
equal to infinity.
And the variance of the sample
average as n goes to infinity
is equal to 0.
And that's because of this 1
over n squared effect here.
When you add up a lot of
independent random variables,
what you wind up with is the
sample average has a variance,
which is going to 0.
And the sum has a variance which
is going to infinity.
That's important.
Aside from all of the theorems
you've ever heard, this is
sort of the gross, simple-minded
thing which you
always ought to keep foremost
in your mind.
This is what's happening
in probability theory.
When you talk about sample
averages, this variance is
getting small.
Let's look at a picture
of this.
Let's look at the distribution
function
of this random variable.
The sample average as
a random variable.
And what we're finding here
is that this distribution
function, if we look at it for
some modest value of n, we get
something which looks like
this upper curve here.
Which is then the lower
curve here.
It's spread out more, so it
has a larger variance.
Namely, the sample average
When you make n bigger, what's
happening to the variance?
The variance is getting
smaller.
The variance is getting smaller
by a factor of 1/2.
So this quantity is supposed
to have a variance which is
equal to 1/2 of the
variance of this.
How you find a variance
in a distribution
function is your problem.
But you know that if something
has a small variance, it's
very closely tucked
in around this.
In other words, as the variance
goes to 0, and the
mean is y bar, you have a
distribution function which
approaches a unit step.
And all that just comes from
this very, very simple
argument that says, when you
have a sum of IID random
variables and you take the
sample average of it, namely,
you divide by n, the
variance goes to 0.
Which says, no matter how you
look at it, you wind up with
something that looks
like a unit step.
Now, the Chebyshev inequality,
which is one of the simpler
inequalities in probability
theory, and I don't prove it
because it's something
you've all seen.
I don't know of any course in
probability which avoids the
Chebyshev inequality.
And what it says is, for any
epsilon greater than 0, the
probability that the difference
between the sample
average and the true mean, the
probability that that quantity
and magnitude is greater than
or equal to epsilon, is less
than or equal to sigma
sub y squared divided
by n epsilon squared.
Oh, incidentally that thing that
was called sigma sub n
before was really
sigma squared.
That's mainly the
variance of y.
I hope it's right
in the notes.
Might not be.
It is?
Good.
So, that's what this
inequality says.
There's an easy way to derive
this on the fly.
Namely, if you're wondering what
all these constants are
here, here's a way to do it.
What we're looking at, in this
curve here, is we're trying to
say, how much probability is
there outside of these plus
and minus epsilon limits.
And the Chebyshev inequality
says there can't be too much
probability out here.
And there can't be too much
So, one way to get at this is
to say, OK, suppose I have
some given probability
out here.
And some given probability
And suppose I want to minimize
the variance of a random
variable which has that much
probability out here and that
much probability out here.
How do I do it?
Well, the variance deals with
the square of how far you were
away from the mean.
So if I want to have a certain
amount of probability out
here, I minimize my variance by
making this come straight,
come up here with a little step,
then go across here.
Go up here.
And then, oops.
I wish I had my red pencil.
Does anybody have a red pen?
That will write on this stuff?
Yes?
No?
Oh, great.
Thank you.
I will return it.
So what we want is something
which goes over here.
Comes up here.
Goes across here.
Goes up here.
Goes across here, and
goes up again.
That's the smallest you
can make the variance.
It's squeezing everything
in as far as it
can be squeezed in.
Namely, everything out
here gets squeezed
in to y minus epsilon.
Everything in here gets
squeezed into 0.
And everything out here gets
squeezed into epsilon.
OK, calculate the
variance there.
And that satisfies
the Chebyshev
inequality with equality.
So that's all the Chebyshev
inequality is.
And it's a loose inequality
usually, because usually these
curves look very nice.
Usually this looks like a
Gaussian distribution
function, and the central limit
theorem says that we
don't need the central limit
theorem here, and we don't
want the central limit theorem
here, because this thing is an
inequality that says, life can't
be any worse than this.
And all the central limit
theorem is, is an
approximation.
And then we have to worry
about when it's a good
approximation and when it's
not a good approximation.
So this says, when we carry it
one piece further, it's for
any epsilon and delta
greater than 0.
If we make n large enough --
in other words, substitute
delta for this.
And then, when you make n small
enough, this quantity is
smaller than delta.
And that says that the
probability that s and y
differ by more than epsilon is
less than or equal to delta
when we make n big enough.
So it says, you can make this
as small as you want.
You can make this as
small as you want.
And all you need to do
is make a sequence
which is long enough.
Now, the thing which is
mystifying about the law of
large numbers is, you
need both the
epsilon and the delta.
You can't get rid of
either of them.
In other words, you
can't say --
you can't reduce this to 0.
Because it won't
make any sense.
In other words, this
curve here tends to
spread out on its tails.
And therefore, there's always a
probability of error there.
You can't move epsilon into 0
because, for no finite end, do
you really get a step
function here.
So you need some wiggle
room on both end.
You need wiggle room here, and
you need wiggle room here.
And once you recognize that you
need those two pieces of
wiggle room.
Namely, you cannot talk about
the probability that this is
equal to y bar, because
that's usually 0.
And you cannot talk about
reducing this to 0 either.
So both of those are needed.
Why did I go through
all of this?
Well, partly because
it's important.
But partly because I want to
talk about something which is
called the asymptotic
equipartition property.
And because of those long words
you believe this has to
be very complicated.
I hope to convince you that
what the asymptotic
equipartition property is, is
simply the week law of large
numbers applied to
the log pmf.
Because that, in fact,
is all it is.
But it says some unusual
and fascinating things.
So let's suppose that x1, x2,
and so forth is the output
from a discrete memoryless
source.
Look at the log pmf
of each of these.
Namely, they each have the same
distribution function.
So w of f x is going to be equal
to minus the logarithm
of p sub x of x, for each of
these chance variables.
w of x maps source symbols
into real numbers.
So there's a random variable,
capital W of x sub j, which is
a random variable.
We have a random variable for
each one of these symbols to
come out of the source.
So, for each one of these
symbols, there's this log pmf
random variable, which takes
on different values.
So the expected value of this
log pmf, for the j'th symbol
out of the source is the sum
of p sub x of x, namely the
probability that the source
takes on the value x, times
minus the logarithm
of p sub x.
And that's just the entropy.
So, the strange feeling about
this log pmf random variable
is its expected value
is entropy.
And w of x1, w of x2, and so
forth, are a sequence of IID
random variables, each one of
them which has a mean, which
is the entropy.
So it's just exactly the
situation we had before.
Instead of y bar, we have
the entropy of x.
And instead of the random
variable y sub j, we have this
random variable w of x sub j,
which is defined by the symbol
in an alphabet.
And just to review this, but
it's what we said before, if
capital X1, this little x1,
namely, if little x1 is the
sample value for the chance
variable x1 and if x2 is a
variable X2, then the outcome
for w of x1 plus w of x2 --
very hard to keep all these
little letters and capital
letters straight.
Is w of x1 plus w of x2 is minus
the logarithm of the
probability of x1 minus the
logarithm of the probability
of x2, which is minus the
logarithm of the product,
which is minus the logarithm of
the joint probability of x1
and x2, which is the random
variable w of x1 x2.
So the sum here is the random
variable corresponding to log
pmf of the joint outputs
x1 and x2.
So w of x1 x2 is the log pmf of
the event, but this joint
chance variable takes
on the value x1 x2.
And the random variable x1 x2
is the sum of x1 and x2.
So, what have I done here?
I said this at the end of the
last slide, and you won't
believe me.
So, again this is one of these
things where tomorrow you
won't believe me.
And you'll have to go back
and look at that.
But, anyway, x1 x2 is
a chance variable.
And probabilities multiply in
log pmf's add, which is what
we've been saying for a
couple of days now.
So.
If I look at the sum of n of
these random variables, the
sum of these log probabilities
is the sum of the log of
pmf's, which is minus the
logarithm of the probability
of the entire sequence.
That's just saying the same
thing we said before, for two
random variables.
The sample average of a log
pmf's is the sum of the w's
divided by n, which is minus
the logarithm of the
probability divided by n.
The weak law of large numbers
applies, and the probability
that this sample average minus
the expected value of w of x
is greater than or equal to
epsilon is less than or equal
to this quantity here.
This quantity is minus the
logarithm of the probability
of x sub n, divided by n, minus
H of x, greater than or
equal to epsilon.
So this is the thing that
we really want.
I'm going to spend a few
slides trying to
say what this means.
But let's try to just look
at it now, and see
what it must mean.
It says that with high
probability, this quantity is
almost the same as
this quantity.
It says that with high
probability, the thing which
comes out of the source is going
to have a probability, a
log probability, divided by n,
which is close to the entropy.
It says in some sense that with
high probability, the
probability of what
comes out of the
source is almost a constant.
And that's amazing.
That's what you'll wake up in
the morning and say, I don't
believe that.
But it's true.
But you have to be careful
to interpret it right.
So, we're going to define
the typical set.
Namely, this is the typical set
of x's, which come out of
the source.
Namely, the typical
set of blocks of n
symbols out of the source.
And when you talk about a
typical set, you want
something which includes most
of the probability.
So what I'm going to include in
this typical set is all of
these things that we talked
about before.
Namely, we showed that the
probability that this quantity
is greater than or equal to
epsilon is very small.
So, with high probability what
comes out of the source
satisfies this inequality
here.
So I can write down the
distribution function of this
random variable here.
It's just this w --
this is a random variable w.
I'm looking at the distribution
of that random
variable w.
And this quantity in here is
the probability of this
typical set.
In other words, when I draw this
distribution function for
this combined random variable,
I've defined this typical set
to be all the sequences which
lie between this point and
this point.
Namely, this is H
minus epsilon.
And this is H plus epsilon,
moving H out here.
So these are all the sequences
which satisfy
this inequality here.
So that's what I mean
by the typical set.
It's all things which are
clustered around H in this
distribution function.
And as n approaches infinity,
this typical set approaches
probability 1.
In the same way that the
law of large numbers
behaves that way.
The probability that x sub n
is in this typical set is
greater than or equal to 1 minus
sigma squared divided by
n epsilon squared.
Let's try to express that in
a bunch of other ways.
If you're getting lost,
please ask questions.
But I hope to come back to this
in a little bit, after we
finish a little more
of the story.
So, another way of expressing
this typical set -- let me
look at that as the
typical set.
If I take this inequality here
and I rewrite this, namely,
this is the set of x's for
which this is less than
epsilon plus H of x
and greater than
H of x minus epsilon.
So that's what I've
expressed here.
It's the set of x's for which
n times H of x minus epsilon
is less than this logarithm of
probability is great less than
n times H of x plus epsilon.
Namely, I'm looking at this
range of epsilon around H,
which is this and this.
If I write it again, if I
exponentiate all of this, it's
the set of x's for which 2 to
the minus n, H of x, plus
epsilon, that's this term
exponentiated, is less than
this is less than this
term exponentiated.
And what's going on here
is, I've taken care of
the minus sign also.
And if you can follow that in
your head, you're a better
person than I am.
But, anyway, it works.
And if you fiddle around with
that, you'll see that that's
what it is.
So this typical set is a bound
on the probabilities of all
these typical sequences.
The typical sequences all are
enclosed in this range of
probabilities.
So the typical elements are
approximately equiprobable, in
this strange sense above.
Why do I say this is
a strange sense?
Well, as n gets large,
what happens here?
This is 2 to the minus
n times H of x.
Which is the important
part of this.
This epsilon here is
multiplied by n.
And we're trying to say, as n
gets very, very big, we can
make epsilon very, very small.
But we really can't make n times
epsilon very negligible.
But the point is, the important
thing here is, 2 to
the minus n times H of x.
So, in some sense, this
is close to 2 to the
minus n H of x.
In what sense is it true?
Well, it's true in that sense.
Where that, in fact is,
a valid inequality.
Namely in terms of
sample averages,
these things are close.
When I do the exponentiation and
get rid of the n and all
that stuff, they aren't
very close.
But saying this sort of thing is
sort of like saying that 10
to the minus 23 is approximately
equal to 10 to
the minus 25.
And they're approximately equal
because they're both
very, very small.
And that's the kind of thing
that's going on here.
And you're trying to distinguish
10 to the minus 23
and 10 to the minus 25 from 10
to the minus 60th and from 10
to the minus three.
So that's the kind of
approximations we're using.
Namely, we're using
approximations on a log scale,
instead of approximations
of ordinary numbers.
But, still it's convenient to
think of these typical x's,
typical sequences, as being
sequences which are
constrained in probability
in this way.
And this is the thing which
is easy to work with.
The atypical set of strings,
namely, the compliment to this
set, the thing we know about
that is the entire set doesn't
have much probability.
Namely, if you fix epsilon and
you let n get bigger and
bigger, this atypical set
becomes totally negligible.
And you can ignore it.
So let's plow ahead.
Stop for an example pretty
soon, but --
If I have a sequence which is
in the typical set, we then
know that its probability is
greater than 2 to the minus n
times H of x plus epsilon.
That's what we said before.
And, therefore, when I use
this inequality, the
probability of x to the n, for
something in the typical set,
is greater than this
quantity here.
In other words, this is
greater than that.
For everything in
a typical set.
So now I'm heading over things
in a typical set.
So I need to include the
number of things
in a typical set.
So what I have is this sum.
And what is this sum?
This is the probability
of the typical set.
Because I'm adding overall
elements in the typical set.
And it's greater than or equal
to the number of elements in a
typical set times these
small probabilities.
If I turn this around, it says
that the number of elements in
a typical set is less
than 2 to the n
times H of x plus epsilon.
For any epsilon, no matter how
small I want to make it.
Which says that the elements
in a typical set have
probabilities which are about 2
to the minus n times H of x.
And the number of them is
approximately 2 to the
n times H of x.
In other words, what it says is
that this typical set is a
bunch of essentially uniform
probabilities.
So what I've done is to take
this very complicated source.
And when I look at these very
humongous chance variables,
which are very large sequences
out of the source, what I find
is that there's a bunch of
things which collectively have
zilch probability.
There's a bunch of other things
which all have equal
probability.
And a number of them is
enough to add up to y.
So I have turned this source,
when I look at it over a long
enough sequence, into a source
of equiprobable events.
And each of those events has
this probability here.
Now, we know how to encode
equiprobable events.
And that's the whole
point of this.
So, this is less than
or equal to that.
On the other side, we know that
1 minus delta is less
than or equal to this
probability of a typical set.
And this is less than the
number of elements in a
typical set times 2 to the minus
n h of x minus epsilon.
This is an upper
bound on this.
This is less than this.
So I just add all these things
up and I get this bound.
So it says, the size of the
typical set is greater than 1
minus delta, times
this quantity.
In other words, this is a pretty
exact sort of thing.
If you don't mind dealing
with this 2 to the n
epsilon factor here.
If you agree that that's
negligible in some strange
sense, the all of this
makes good sense.
And if it is negligible, let me
start talking about source
coding, which is why
this all works out.
So the summary is that the
probability of the complement
of the typical set
is essentially 0.
The number of elements in a
typical set is approximately 2
to the n times h of x.
I'm getting rid of all the
deltas and epsilons here, to
get sort of the broad view
of what's important here.
Each of the elements in a
typical set has probability 2
to the minus n times H of x.
So I've turned a source
into a source of
equiprobable elements.
And there are 2 to the n
times h of x of them.
Let's do an example of this.
It's an example that you'll work
on more in the homework
and do it a little
more cleanly.
Let's look at a binary discrete
memoryless source,
where the probability that x is
equal to 1 is p, which is
less than 1/2.
And the probability of 0
is greater than 1/2.
So, this is what you get when
you have a biased coin.
And the biased coin has a
1 on one side and a 0
on the other side.
And it's more likely to
come up 0's than 1's.
I always used to wonder how
to make a biased coin.
And I can give you a little
experiment which shows you you
can make a biased coin.
I mean, a biased is a little
round thing which is flat on
the top and bottom.
Suppose instead of that you
make a triangular coin.
And instead of making it flat on
top and bottom, you turn it
into a tetrahedron.
So in fact, what this is now is
a coin which is built up on
one side into a very
massive thing.
And is flat on the other side.
Since it's a tetrahedron
and it's an equilateral
tetrahedron, the probability of
1 is going to be 1/4, and
the probability of 0
is going to be 3/4.
So you can make biased coins.
So when you get into
coin-tossing games with
people, watch the coin
that they're using.
It probably won't be a
tetrahedron, but anyway.
So the entropy here, the log pmf
random variable, takes on
the value of minus log
p with probability p.
And it takes on the value minus
log 1 minus p, with
probability 1 minus p.
This is a probability of a 1.
This is a probability of a 0.
So, the entropy is
equal to this.
Used to be that in information
theory courses, people would
almost memorize what this
curve looked like.
And they'd draw pictures
of it.
There were famous curves
of this function,
which looks like this.
0, 1, 1.
Turns out, that's not all that
important a distribution.
It's a nice example
to talk about.
The typical set, t epsilon n,
is the set of strings with
about p n1's and about 1
minus p times n 0's.
In other words, that's the
typical thing to happen.
And it's the typical thing in
terms of this law of large
numbers here.
Because you get 1's with
probability p.
And therefore in a long
sequence, you're going to get
about pn 1's and
1 minus p 0's.
The probability of a typical
string is, if you get a string
with this many 1's and
this many 0's, it's
probability is p.
Namely, the probability of a 1
times the number of 1's you
get, which is pn.
Times the probability
of a 0, times the
number of 0's you get.
And if you look at what this
is, if you take p up in the
exponent and 1 minus the p up in
the exponent, this becomes
2 to the minus n times h of x,
just like what it should be.
So these typical strings, with
about pn 1's and 1 minus pn
0's, are in fact typical
in the sense we've
been talking about.
The number of n strings with pn
1's is n factorial divided
by pn factorial divided by n
times 1 minus p factorial.
I mean I hope you learned that
a long time ago, but you
should learn it in probability
anyway.
It's just very simple
combinatorics.
So you have that many
different strings.
So what I'm trying to get across
here is, there are a
bunch of different things
going on here.
We can talk about the random
variable which is the number
of 1's that occur in
this long sequence.
And with high probability, the
number of 1's that occur is
close to pn.
But if pn 1's occur, there's
still an awful lot of
randomness left.
Because we have to worry about
where those pn 1's appear.
And those are the sequences
we're talking about.
So, there are this many
sequences, all of which have
that many 1's in them.
And there's a similar number of
sequences for all similar
numbers of 1's.
Namely, if you take pn plus 1
and pn plus 2, pn minus 1, pn
minus 2, you get similar
numbers here.
So those are the typical
sequences.
Now, the important thing to
observe here is that you
really have 2 to the n binary
strings altogether.
And what this result is saying
is that collectively those
don't make any difference.
The law of large numbers says,
OK, there's just a humongous
number of strings.
You get the largest number
strings which have about half
1's and half 0's.
But their probability
is zilch.
So the thing which is probable
is getting pn 1's
and 1 minus pn 0's.
Now, we have this typical set.
What is the most likely sequence
of all, in this
experiment?
How do I maximize the
probability of
a particular sequence?
The probability of the sequence
is p to the i times 1
minus p to the n minus i.
And 1 minus p is the
probability of 0.
And p is the probability
of a 1.
How do I choose i to
maximize this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
all 0's.
PROFESSOR: You make
them all 0's.
So the most likely sequence
is all 0's.
But that's not a typical
sequence.
Why isn't it a typical
sequence?
Because we chose to define
typical sequence in a
different way.
Namely is only one of those, and
there are only n of them
with only a single one.
So, in other words, what's going
on is that we have an
enormous number of sequences
which have around half
1's and half 0's.
But they don't have
any probability.
And collectively they don't
have any probability.
We have a very small number of
sequences which have a very
large number of 0's.
But there aren't enough of those
to make any difference.
And, therefore, the things that
make a difference are
these typical things which
have about np 1's
and 1 minus pn 0's.
And that all sounds
very strange.
But if I phrase this a different
way, you would all
say that's exactly the way
you ought to do things.
Because, in fact, when we look
at very, very long sequences,
you know with extraordinarily
high probability what's going
to come out of the source is
something with about pn 1's
and about 1 minus
p times n 0's.
So that's the likely set of
things to have happen.
And it's just that there
are an enormous
number of those things.
There are this many of them.
So, here what we're dealing with
is a balance between the
number of elements of a
particular type, and the
probability of them.
And it turns out that this
number and its probability
balance out to say that usually
what you get is about
pn 1's and 1 minus
p times n 0's.
Which is what the law of large
numbers said to begin with.
All we're doing is interpreting
that here.
But the thing that you see from
this example is, all of
these things with exactly pn 1's
in them, assuming that pn
is an integer, are
all equiprobable.
They're all exactly
equiprobable.
So what we're doing when we're
talking about this typical
set, is first throwing out all
the things which have to many
1's are or too few
1's in them.
We're keeping only the ones
which are typical in the sense
that they obey the law
of large numbers.
And in this case, they obey the
law of large numbers for
log pmf's also.
And then all of those things
are about equally probable.
So the idea in source coding
is, one of the ways to deal
with source coding is, you want
to assign codewords to
only these typical things.
Now, maybe you might want to
assign codewords to something
like all 0's also.
Because it hardly
costs anything.
And a Huffman code would
certainly do that.
But it's not very important
whether you do or not.
The important thing is, you
assign codewords to all of
these typical sequences.
So let's go back to
fixed-to-fixed
length source codes.
We talked a little bit about
fixed-to-fixed length source
codes before.
Do you remember what we did
with fixed-to-fixed length
source codes before?
We said we have an alphabet
of size m.
We want something which
is uniquely decodable.
And since we want something
which is uniquely decodable,
we have to provide codewords
for everything.
And, therefore, if we want to
choose a block length of n,
we've got to generate m
to the n codewords.
Here we say, wow, maybe we
don't have to provide
codewords for everything.
Maybe we're willing to tolerate
a certain small
probability that the whole
thing fails and
falls on its face.
Now, does that make any sense?
Well, view things the
following way.
We said, when we started out
all of this, that we were
going to look at prefix-free
codes.
Where some codewords had a
longer length and some
codewords had a shorter
length.
And we were thinking of encoding
either single letters
at a time, or a small block
of letters at a time.
So think of encoding, say,
10 letters at a time.
And think of doing this for
10 to the 20th letters.
So you have the source here
which is pumping out letters
at a regular rate.
You're blocking them into
n letters at a time.
You're encoding in a
prefix-free code.
Out comes something.
What comes is not coming
out at a regular right.
What is coming out, sometimes
you get a lot of bits out.
Sometimes a small number
of bits out.
So, in other words, if you want
to send things over a
channel, you need a buffer
there to save things.
If, in fact, we decide that the
expected number of bits
per source letter is, say, five
bits per source letter,
then we expect over a very long
time to be producing five
bits per source letter.
And if we turn our channel on
for one year, to transmit all
of these things, what's going
to happen is this very
unlikely sequence occurs.
Which in fact requires not one
year to transmit, but two
years to transmit.
In fact, what do we do if it
takes one year and five
minutes to transmit instead
of one year?
Well, we've got a failure.
Somehow or other, the network
is going to fail us.
I mean we all know that networks
fail all the time
despite what engineers say.
I mean, all of us who use
networks know that they do
crazy things.
And one of those crazy things
is that unusual things
sometimes happen.
So, we develop this very nice
theory of prefix-free codes.
But prefix-free codes,
in fact, fail also.
And they fail also because
buffers overflow.
In other words, we are counting
on encoding things
with a certain number of
bits per source symbol.
And if these unusual things
occur, and we have too many
bits per source symbol,
then we fail.
So the idea that we're trying
to get at now is that
prefix-free codes and
fixed-to-fixed length source
codes which only encode
typical things.
In fact, are sort of the same
if you look at them over a
very, very large sequence
length.
In other words, if you look at
a prefix-free code which is
dealing with blocks of 10
letters, and you look at a
fixed-to-fixed length code which
is only dealing with
typical things but is looking at
a length of 10 to the 20th,
then over that length of 10 to
the 20th, your variable length
code is going to have a bunch of
things which are about the
length they ought to be.
And a bunch of other
things which are
extraordinarily long.
The bunch of things which are
extraordinarily long are
extraordinarily unpopular, but
there are an extraordinarily
large number of them.
Just like with a fixed-to-fixed
length code,
you are going to fail.
And you're going to fail on
an extraordinary number of
different sequences.
But, collectively, that set of
sequences don't have any
probability.
So the point that I'm trying to
get across is that, really,
these two situations come
together when we look very
long lengths.
Namely, prefix-free codes are
just a way of generating codes
that work for typical sequences
and over a very
large, long period of time, will
generate about the right
number of symbols.
And that's what I'm trying
to get at here.
Or what I'm trying to get
at in the next slide.
So the fixed-to-fixed length
source code, I'm going to pick
some epsilon and some delta.
Namely, that epsilon and delta
which appeared in the law of
large numbers.
I'm going to make n as big as
I have to make it for that
epsilon and that delta.
And calculate how large it
has to be, but we won't.
Then I'm going to assign fixed
length codewords to each
sequence in the typical set.
Now, am I going to really build
something which does this?
Of course not.
I mean, I'm talking about
truly humongous lengths.
So, this is really a conceptual
tool to understand
what's going on.
It's not something we're
going to implement.
So I'm going to assign
codewords to all
these typical elements.
And then what I find is that
since the typical set, since
the number of elements in it is
less than 2 to the n times
H of x plus epsilon, if I choose
L bar, namely, the
number of bits I'm going to use
for encoding these things,
it's going to have to be H of
x plus epsilon in length.
Because I need to provide
codewords for
each of these things.
And it needs to be an extra 1
over n because of this integer
constraint that we've been
dealing with all along, which
doesn't make any difference.
So if I choose L bar, that big,
in other words, if I make
it just a little bit bigger
than the entropy, the
probability of failure
is going to be less
than or equal to delta.
And I can make delta -- and I
can make the probability of
failure as small as I want.
So I can make this epsilon here
which is the extra bits
per source symbol as
small as I want.
So it says I can come as close
to the entropy bound in doing
this, and come as close to
unique decodability as I want
in doing this.
And I have a fixed-to-fixed
length code, which after one
year is going to stop.
And I can turn my decoder off.
I can turn my encoder off.
I can go buy a new encoder
and a new decoder, which
presumably works a little
bit better.
And there isn't any problem
about when to turn it off.
Because I know I can
turn it off.
Because everything will
have come in by then.
Here's a more interesting
story.
Suppose I choose the number of
bits per source symbol that
I'm going to use to be less than
or equal to the entropy
minus 2 epsilon.
Why 2 epsilon?
Well, just wait a second.
I mean, 2 epsilon is small
and epsilon is small.
But I want to compare with this
other epsilon and my law
of large numbers.
And I'm going to pick
n large enough.
The number of typical sequences,
we said before, was
greater than 1 minus delta times
2 to the n times h of x
minus epsilon.
I'm going to make this epsilon
the same as that epsilon,
which is why I wanted this
to be 2 epsilon.
So my typical set is this big
when I choose n large enough.
And this says that most
of the typical set
can't be assigned codewords.
In other words, this number
here is humongously larger
then 2 to the l bar, which is in
the order of 2 to the nh of
x minus 2 epsilon n.
So the fraction of typical
elements that I can provide
codewords for, between this and
this, I can only provide
codewords for a fraction
2 to the minus
epsilon n of the codewords.
We have this big sea of
codewords, which are all
essentially equally likely.
And I can't provide codewords
for even a
small fraction of them.
So the probability of failure is
going to be 1 minus delta.
The 1 minus delta's the
probability that I get
something atypical.
Plus, well, minus in this case,
2 to the minus epsilon
n, which is the probability that
I can't encode a typical
codeword that comes out.
And this quantity goes to 1.
So this says that if I'm willing
to use a number of
bits bigger than the entropy, I
can succeed with probability
very close to 1.
And if I want to use a smaller
number of bits, I fail with
probability 1.
Which is the same as saying that
I'm using a prefix-free
code, I'm going to run out of
buffer space eventually if I
run long enough.
If I have something that
I'm encoding --
well, just erase that.
I'll say it more carefully
later.
I do want to talk a little bit
about this Kraft inequality
for unique decodability.
You remember we proved the
Kraft inequality for
prefix-free codes.
I now want to talk about the
Kraft inequality for uniquely
decodable codes.
And you might think that I've
done all of this development
of the AEP, the asymptotic
equipartition property.
Incidentally, you now know where
those words come from.
It's asymptotic because this
result is valid asymptotically
as n goes to infinity.
It's equipartition because
everything is equally likely.
And its property, because
it's a property.
So it's the asymptotic
equipartition property.
And I didn't do it so I could
prove the Kraft inequality.
It's just that that's an extra
bonus that we get.
And by understanding why the
Kraft inequality has to hold
for uniquely decodable codes, if
is one application for AEP
which lets you see a little
bit about how to use it.
OK, so the argument is an
argument by contradiction.
Suppose you generate a set
of lengths for codewords.
And you want this -- yeah?
And the thing you would like to
do is to assign codewords
of these lengths.
And what we want to do is to
set this equal to some
quantity b.
In other words, suppose we beat
the Kraft inequality.
Suppose we can make the lengths
even shorter than
Kraft says we can make them.
I mean, he was only a graduate
student, so we've got to be
able to beat his inequality
somehow.
So we're going to try to
make this equal to b.
We're going to assume that
b is greater than 1.
And then what we're going to
do is to show that we get a
contradiction here.
And this same argument can
work whether we have a
discrete memoryless source or
a source with memory, or
anything else.
It can work with blocks, it can
work with variable length
to variable length codes.
It's all essentially
the same argument.
So what I want to do is to
get a contradiction.
I'm going to choose a discrete
memoryless source.
And I'm going to make the
probabilities equal to 1 over
b times 2 to the minus li.
In other words, I can generate
a discrete memoryless source
for talking about it with
any probabilities I
want to give it.
So I'm going to generate one
with these probabilities.
So the lengths are going to
be equal to minus log of
b times p sub i.
Which says that the expected
length of the codewords is
equal to the sum of p sub i l
sub i, which is equal to the
entropy minus the
logarithm of b.
Which means I can get an
expected length which is a
little bit less than
the entropy.
So now what I'm going to do is
to consider strings of n
source letters.
I'm going to make these string
very, very long.
When I concatenate all these
codewords, I'm going to wind
up with a length that's less
than n times H of x minus b
over 2, minus log b over 2
with high probability.
And as a fixed-length code of
this length it's going to have
a low failure probability.
And, therefore, what this says
is I can, using this
remarkable code with unique
decodability, and generating
very long strings from it, I
can generate a fixed-length
code which has a low failure
probability.
And I just showed you
in the last slide
that I can't do that.
The probability of failure with
such a code has to be
essentially 1.
So that's a contradiction that
says you can't have these
unique decodable codes.
If you didn't get that in what
I said, don't be surprised.
Because all I'm trying to do is
to steer you towards how to
look at the section in the
notes that does that.
It was a little too fast
and a little too late.
But, anyway, that is the Kraft
inequality for unique
decodability.
OK, thanks.